I'm in the Masters of Fine Arts program
this is my third year this is a project
that came out of a class they're called
community affiliation and so this
project is kind of two years old yeah we
do a mixture of plan and spontaneous
showing so some of the places we go our
surprise and we go there in our free
time whenever we want you know whoever
the audience's whoever happens to be
there go a lot of times people will see
it and because the sitting still you
know introduce it isn't as a mobile
thing that we're taking over the city
and then they'll look up and be like oh
it's attached to a bike oh wow one of
the important sort of technical
statements about the body of work that
is that the mobile museum is that all
the work is that the total cost of
materials is close to zero because all
the materials are gathered and reclaimed
found objects so I make a very sort of
careful selection of materials try to
find things that have value in
themselves and then also the way I go
about creating them is kind of like I
make conscious processes or rituals to
arrive at the solutions a lot of people
ask me how old are these and I say there
are 5000 year old pieces that i made
last year because i like to build that
history into the material i was really
thankful that alley stop by my door
wanting to do this mobile museum project
because otherwise my art would just be
in my studio and i have tons of art that
never
shown to the public and so Ali kind of
made it possible for my art to come out
into the world
you